solve most of our problems but it ends
up being a relatively poor abstraction
you know it's distracting away the
mechanics of making the HTTP request
rather than embracing the bits about
HTTP that actually make it useful and
you know even then I didn't actually
show it but you know that abstraction
was also leaking details still so it was
a leaky abstraction because we still got
the response back which would be just
the normal jquery ajax response with all
the HTTP response details in it so you
know this isn't a problem that specific
to jquery by any means and i don't mean
to pick on jquery it's just you know
it's one of the most popular library so
it's the easiest to demonstrate every
library that has some like Ajax
functionality tends to have this
fundamental issue so really kind of what
the present here is to really kind of
think about what the abstractions that
we should be doing and we should be
working with the resources and HTTP is
fundamentally about getting and
manipulating resources on a server
rather than dealing with the low-level
mechanics of actually how do we make a
request so there's a little library that
I created call dress gasps it's a very
thin wrapper around that basically the
raw of request and response I mentioned
earlier works with the xhr as well as
nodes HTTP libraries also have support
for Jason P and even i use cross-domain
request runs in common Jas and AMD so
whatever environment you want to work
with you know we're using modules it's
so you know if you're not familiar with
modules everyone in node you know it's
just a straight-up require rest it's
dead simple being a browser typically we
require an AMD loader so if you're not
familiar with that you basically just
define your module and your specify your
requirements and they get injected and
at runtime so how do what is restaurants
actually look like at runtime well we
have this rest function and we can then
again get that URL and it returns a
promise for the response and you know if
you think about what I just chose
talking about with jquery I mean this is
exactly the same pattern so you know I
must obviously not be very good what I
do
so before I get really into deep about
what makes rest rest there's a concept
out there of the Richardson maturity
model and this is basically you know
anytime someone starts talking about a
maturity model you know pay attention
figure out what they're talking about
figure out how much of it really is
important to you and then just you know
figure off where you want to get off the
train but at the very low level you know
what they call level zero it's basically
just you know random request going off
all over the place that have really no
semantic meaning but you know somehow
the client and server figure out what to
do the level one is where you actually
start using resources so instead of the
you know you can actually start to
access things of the more resource
oriented fashion rather than trying to
do RPC over HTTP or some other you know
hack level two is actually using HTTP
verbs so you know using gets to load
resources put to create resources put to
modify resources or create more
resources and then you know finally
level three is you know using hypermedia
api's so if you think about the web you
have a page of links and when you
navigate to that page you get the links
and you get the context of it and then
you figure out okay I want to follow
that link and then you get another page
it has to get more length and you keep
following that so the idea of hypermedia
resources is that for your actual for
your data API s you again have resources
with collection of links and you
navigate those links that reverse the
object graph rather than having to
figure out what the URL structure is in
advance that that server has support and
then going through and parsing that out
yourself
so back to what r SJ s is so it
mentioned earlier it's an abstraction to
work with resources rather than just an
abstraction to make requests so of
course we give you full access to the
request and response objects you know
all the properties that you can put on
to a request or a response you have
access to but really the advantages that
we have this notion of an interceptor
that allows you to really apply advanced
behavior to that core request response
facility so that we're not baking in a
bunch of knowledge into the actual
lowest level client but we're applying
it on after the fact really what that
allows you to do is configure your
clients once and then share them with
your application so digging into what
actually an interceptor is it kind of
just talked about that so let's actually
show one so in this case we basically
start with the rest client and then
we're going to chain off of that the
basic auth interceptor and to that
interceptor we give it a little bit of
configuration so we can give it a
username and the password then basically
we get back a resulting client and that
client again is just another function
where you can pass the same request
structure to and basically what happens
under the hood is that before making
that request it'll actually apply that
using password and actually authenticate
it for you so that the response is the
authenticated resource instead of just
anonymous resource so what can
interceptors do you know really just
about anything so they fundamentally
hook and intercept into the requester
relax respond to life cycle so that they
can either augment a request response or
replace it entirely they can follow the
natural chain of interceptors or they
can replace it and send them somewhere
off its somewhere completely different
they can also detect and recover from
air sea and promises has the notion of a
successful resolution versus an air
state so it can push that promise into
one or the other states and of course it
can also abort the request if you don't
want to wait for it anymore so the only
thing interceptors really can't do is
alter another configured client because
a client is just a function functions
closure you can't manipulate it once
it's created so that's actually also
what makes it safe to take a client
that's bumped configured and share it
with that within your application so out
of the box we have several different
interceptors some of them are just low
level basic things like being able to
default different portions of the
request like if you always want to add
certain headers to your request you know
you can do that or if you only really
care about the response entity instead
of the response headers and other meta
information like the status code there's
restful interceptors so there's a mime
interceptor that handles content
negotiation so I mean that ends up being
also kind of a nice feature you know in
HTTP what you're supposed to do
typically is set the accepts header on
the request that says what I'm
interested in receiving in terms of a
content type then the server decides
okay you wanted application Jason I know
how to create a patient Jason so well as
what I'll give you but then the receiver
sets the response content type as
application Jason when it sends back the
response so this header there this
interceptor also parses the response
based off of a return concept type so
many other libraries will just say I'm
just going to assume that I'm going to
get back Jason and if it gives back
Jason it works if you get back something
else you know many servers if you have a
500 air will give you back HTML by
default it'll still try and parse that
as Jason and you get an even bigger air
also in terms of authentication sought a
basic off interceptor there's also an
Olaf interceptor in terms of errors we
have to basically the ability to trigger
air is based off the response code the
ability to retry failed requests as well
as to just timeout and stop then finally
some of the fall backs support for a
JSONP for Jason P based services
obviously that one's browser only and
within IE have support for cross the
main request as well as trying to you
use the activex a check xhr support for
older versions of ie so basically you
just add those interceptors and just
does it correct so interceptors also
really easy to create your own and
configure your own so fundamentally it's
just a function that you give it a few
other functions so just a few different
phases of the request so most of the
time you know you're going to deal with
either the requested a response phase of
the interceptor so that means is when a
request is going in that function will
be called and then you can choose to
return either just a modified request or
you can actually trace it with something
entirely else and any of these phases
you can always return a promise for a
future value if you need to go off and
do some other asynchronous work within
the request and response interceptors
you also or phases of the Interceptor
you also get access to a configuration
object so for that basic auth
interceptor we were passing in a
username and password configuration so
those become available in these
callbacks and you can parcel map used as
as values success and error is really
just specializations of response so
whether or not the promise of the parent
client was in their successful state or
whether was in a narrow state so what
does it interceptor actually look like
in real life they're very very simple
the other way it's set up is that you
know you want to plot do and just like
any other type of programming in the
function you want it to do one thing and
you want to do it well so for a basic
auth interceptor really all we're doing
is getting access to their request
headers object trying to figure out the
username and password that we want to
use it will look on the request object
first otherwise it falls back to the
config and then finally you know
assuming that a user name is provided
it'll actually set the authorization
header basically encoding basics before
the username and password together and
it finally returns that response back
through and the request continues on
so within these interceptors you know
because we have interceptors that have
small chunks of behavior we really want
to be able to apply them together in
aggregate so the notion of chaining
interceptors together becomes really
important you can basically create a
pipeline of behavior that gets applied
to the request and response as it flows
through that interceptor chain so what
does it actually look like so
essentially it's just you know you get a
client and there's a method on that
client called chain which you can give
the interceptor implementation as well
as configuration for the interceptor if
it has any so in this case you know
we're taking that same basic off
interceptor and then we're chaining it
in applying the air code interceptor
which basically says you know in this
case if there's a 500 level or greater
response code then take that route value
and basically treat it as an error
instead of as a successful response and
then after that we basically chain in
the mime interceptor which is what does
the content negotiation and then finally
after that we chain in the hay dos
interceptor which is what does the hydro
media API support so these things
together you can figure out exactly what
you actually care about in terms of the
resource that you're trying to access
and you can then figure out what
features you need to actually support
you can figure out how they apply
together so another thing that's really
common is to take the the retry client
if you're waiting for some resource to
become available on the server say like
j/s comp registration basically you can
just keep checking to see if something's
available using some sort of intercept
you can set it into a successful or air
state if it failed you can retry again
and then finally you can set a time out
kind of after a blow that to say the
whole thing if it takes longer than you
know 10 minutes just give up
so realistically in practice the other
big benefit is that because we have this
configuration that's you know configured
once and then shared within the
application it's really easy to make
modifications for things so if we take
that previous interceptor and let's say
you know my boss comes to me and says
you know I heard about OAuth I really
kind of want you to try and look at you
actually utilizing oh off in your
application that's something where most
HTTP you clients are just going to fall
over flat they don't support it out of
the box you know you're kind of screwed
you have to go find some other client
act like you understand excuse me have
to go find some other clients actually
understands oooff and then figure out
whether that understands how to actually
interact with everything else that you
actually cared about making a request
well with rest GS is actually pretty
simple basically all we have to do is
pop off that basic auth interceptor and
apply in the OAuth interceptor and that
Oh F interceptor actually has a little
bit more config because it off is it a
little bit more complex but
fundamentally the other interceptors in
the chain don't really care what was
before them they just get the request in
the response and the clients that are
actually making the request trying to
get back data also don't really need to
kindercare that it was Oh auth under the
hood the other thing that's really
useful here particularly with OAuth
because you have to go off to another
server to get an off token have that
come back synchronously and then be able
to actually make requests using that
token you know making sure that you're
using the same token for every single
request becomes really useful so having
one interceptor near the root of your
chain that the rest of your application
can use and share becomes really
valuable because then the rest of your
application can benefit from that token
that got captured and cashed
so kind of switching up a little bit you
know HTTP is just one thing that we have
to use as clients HTTP is really good
for resources it's not really good for
events an event based data transmission
back between servers you know if there
was an event and we actually were
running server side you know maybe we
would use a web hook to be notified of
that something happened on the client we
don't have that option there's no way
for the server to you know establish
connection back to the client so
typically what people do instead is
obviously they use web sockets you know
WebSocket supports full bi-directional
communication you know client server to
client client to server but the problem
with WebSocket libraries at least the
ones that exist today is that they
extract sending receiving of messages
from client to server but they really
don't help you deal with messaging once
you receive the message off of that
socket this is something that the
server-side world has been dealing with
for a long time and there's a book
called enterprise integration patterns
this is basically the Gang of Four for
messaging and ability provides a bunch
of simple patterns to really support
messaging oriented programming and don't
let the word Enterprise scare you I mean
it come came out of enterprise computing
but these patterns are really simple and
if you're using amqp year zeromq or
activemq today you know that's kind of
really what those concepts are built
around so another library out there is
called messages j/s it's also part of
Cujo and it's really an implementation
of the enterprise integration patterns
that really give you the core primitives
of messaging so beyond that there's also
adapters to other types of messaging
systems once you want to leave your
local world and move over and network to
something else so web sockets happens to
be one of those adapters but let's kind
of look at just a brief hello world of
what it looks like in a messaging
environment so you know the first thing
we have to do is require messages and
then we basically get a new bus credit
message
so that's not something that strictly
required the messages object is itself a
bus but when you chain a new bus off of
it you can get a local scope so all of
your names are isolated and don't
collide with anything else so on a bus
we're going to define two channels so in
this case we have a channel called lower
case in a channel upper case so a
channel is just a place where messages
are sent to and other handlers can
subscribe to that channel then we
basically have a transformer so that
transformer is basically has a function
that gets a message and then does
something to that message and returns it
so in this case basically getting a
string and we're calling to uppercase on
it and then in that transformer
basically has a couple configuration
parameters called input and output these
are the channels that we want to
subscribe to so input is the channel
that we want to subscribe to and an
output is the channel that we want to
send to once we've done our work with
that message and then we have an
outbound adapter which is basically just
a way of getting messages out of the
message bus back into regular code so in
this case we're base which is calling
console dot log and subscribing it to
the uppercase channel and then finally
we're going to call bus send to send a
new message to the lower case channel
say hello world then ultimately what
happens is it prints out hello world
capitalized and that's probably a ton of
work for a hello world and yes it is you
know for very simple use cases you know
these patterns are probably overkill but
they really become powerful once you can
actually have the need for decoupling
your application your system zis way we
will show an example of how that power
really pays off in a bit so there's
several other primitives talked about a
few of them you know channel there's
several different types of channels the
channel that we used by default it's
basically a point-to-point channel so if
you have multiple subscribers of that
channel for each message that goes in
the message goes out to one of those
subscribers also have pub/sub channels
you know message comes in everyone who
subscribed get them
in exchange channels which basically
allow you to do topic based routing
either based off of just some dynamic
key or some pattern if you want to
subscribe to similar to how AM PP has a
topic exchanges routing keys I'm also
have notion of a Q channel if you don't
want to have to deal with messages right
away and you want to buffer them up and
then pull them off as needed so within
the channels you can subscribe
unsubscribe there's also the mission of
tapping a channel if you want to be
notified every single time a message
comes in it's really useful for logging
and other types of auditing and then
beyond channels there's a notion of
handlers and handlers are things that
actually do things with messages so we
saw a transformer there's also filtering
routing splitting aggregating basically
everything you kind of want to do with a
message basically that's a handler then
finally we have inbound outbound
adapters as well as inbound and outbound
gateways inbound is coming into the
message bus out bounds going out of the
message bus adapters are typically
unidirectional just you know what's
fire-and-forget gateways typically are
more request reply oriented so basically
it establishes a promise for a response
so let's kind of look at what this
actually ends up looking like so had a
use case where basically had a server
where for every message that came into
it we wanted to send it out to every
single client that was connected so in
this case we have you know messages
again as well as a WebSocket server
library realistically we were using
stock j/s in this case as a server but
it could be just about anything so we're
establishing to pub subchannels this
time metro message is coming from the
client and then messages that we want to
stand back down to the client and then
we have a web based on the WebSocket
server for every connection we want to
take that connection and we have a node
stream gateway so basically this is a
message a set of messaging adapters that
for the notes dream API can basically
take every mess
coming in and put it to the Alpha
Channel and every message that's going
out and put it to the input channel so
basically what we're seeing here is on
that bus we're establishing the Gateway
for that connection all the messages
that are coming in get sent to the from
Channel client because this is on the
server we're going to going out goes
like the other way and then finally what
we're doing is we're forwarding the from
client channel to the to client channel
so basically everything that comes from
a client goes directly back to a client
and because it's pops up every client to
subscribe gets every message that was
received so but there's also a fatal
flaw in here if anybody sees it and it's
that you know we're running within a
single process in the single instance
and you know we're only going to be
getting the connections and subscribing
them to the bus if they happen to be on
the same local node so typically what
you want to do is have some other
messaging gateway on your back-end
server so in this case we're going to
introduce Redis for a very basic pub/sub
so you know requiring the reddest client
and one of the other adapters that we
have set up is for a Redis gateway so
everything else is the same in terms of
how we're interacting with the WebSocket
and the channels but instead of just
forwarding from client to client again
we're actually going to take that those
messages and pass them through Redis for
a very basic pub/sub so messages come
from the client on the WebSocket end up
the server from the server gets sent to
Redis then the though each of those
server nodes is then configured to
connect to Reddit and receive messages
back off of that bus and then those
messages get sent back to every single
client then on the client side you know
again we're going to use sock Jess and
again you know this code should look
very familiar and this you know it's the
exact same API is the exact same
programming model whether your client or
server but in this case we have a
WebSocket gateway setup and that's just
a set of adapters that and understand
the w3c web socket API so in this case
you know it expects to begin
a WebSocket connection so I'm using soft
j s so we can get HTTP fallbacks and
other things in addition to just raw
native web sockets and you know again
you know the the up the input and output
channels are setup subnets just come to
and from the server and we can interact
with them so still have a couple minutes
if you actually want to see this running
you can go to Jas comp cloud foundry com
and I actually have that code running
what you'll see is there's a little
circle that will pop up for every user
and as you move your mouse around the
circle will follow you and basically
what it's doing is it's capturing the
raw mousemove events on the browser
sending them up to the server
distributing them across reddest each of
the instances on the server something
them back down so this application is
actually running with three instances up
on cloud foundry and it's the circles
app sample app in within KU jjs if you
actually want to go grab the source for
it and with that i just want to say
thanks if you have any questions I guess
I have a minute all right so if anyone
wants to talk further just feel free to
grab me I'll be here for the rest of the
conference thanks